remember that if you ever shop on
amazon.com the shopping you do can
support the work we do if first you go
to david pakman.com slash amazon and i
noticed a lot of people from our
audience over the last week buying all
sorts of different energy drinks
including amazon offers bulk packs of
energy drinks uh I still have only ever
tried a few sips of red bull and I found
it absolutely heinous are you into some
of these energy drinks lewis these
energy shots that are sometimes marketed
very aggressively no no there there
pretty much all terrible for you I will
admit that I like the taste of Red Bull
really and in very very very rarely well
I have one what would have to be going
on for you to say I'm now going to have
a redbull it's complete debauchery right
I would have to just for some reason I'm
exhausted and I have to get up and do
stuff and I just like if God forbid you
had to go to work or something like that
yeah well uh if I'd my alarm goes off
and I have to get up and go to work I
might need that yeah have you indulged
in these types of drinks Jason I'm
actually resided for this now I can
master all those four lokos am in
rigging now that's Joe what what is four
loko basically it is alcohol plus energy
drink equals terrible hangover yeah I
thought you it wasn't ideal to combine
stimulant in depressants like caffeine
and alcohol it's not a good idea uh I've
served many Red Bull and vodka if I day
at as a bartender and uh usually the
orders of those are precipitated are
followed by the authorities be brought
in right no not usually but just don't
drink don't drink those all right well
congratulations to whoever decided to at
least save by ordering in bulk that I
respect you know even if I'm not into
the whole uh energy shot thing remember
david pakman.com slash amazon than
anything you buy will support our show